Canada oh hi friends how are you okay
go Canada
congrats Seven Seasons listen there's
only a couple shows that make me
incredibly emotional pose is one of them
Sex In The City Is the other and this is
another series that is always bringing
the raw emotion out of me Anthony I'm
curious who is the most emotional on the
cast and has that changed over the
course of Seven Seasons you're talking
to him
[Laughter]
next question uh tan listen I think a
big theme of this show has always been
showing up for others but also showing
up for ourselves and I don't do that
enough and I don't think enough people
out there show up for themselves on a
daily basis so what would be your advice
to anyone out there
who needs to show up for themselves how
can they do that uh in my opinion it's
it's a really simple thing just think of
the thing that really does bring you Joy
and if you have an opportunity to do it
even for a moment each day find a way to
do it as long as it's not causing harm
to anyone else
yeah listen The Big Easy is known as a
bit of a wild City we know that there's
a lot of Rich history there but there's
a lot of fun that is to be had in the
Big Easy uh caramo tell me who would be
most likely to flash their booty for
some Mardi Gras beads you're speaking to
them
yes
and did you flash any booty or some
Mardi Gras
this is
[Laughter]
there's a lot of beard funerals in
season seven I saw a lot of beard
funerals happening oh yeah Jonathan I
trust you I trust you I get a lot of
flack for this beard right here so is it
time for me to let it go no you better
come at me with that big old Canadian
beer
did I cut off a lot of beards this
season I don't I don't remember we
trimmed some we trimmed some frat beers
for sale I had so much to do on that
episode I don't I I had so much to do I
had to like protect my nose uh like
smelling
like because I had some like nose
receptors that got like burned off
the material there was like these like
it was really intense articles is what
we call them I don't know
either
I'm so sorry supposed to go to Canada
we're fine but you know it was they were
really sweet and I will say though I
feel we always remember during press
weeks how much we hear each other say
the exact same thing so I'm so sorry but
um I really did do my biggest makeovers
ever this season I feel like tan and I
like we're always like a little like you
know power makeover Duo but I feel like
this season we really like and I also
think part of it was our heroes like
having gone through covet for the last
few years like a lot of people like
really are in like bigger hair Reds
bigger style ruts like and are ready to
like break out and make a change so it's
really fun to like have people that were
like ready to rumble like they were
ready to play ready to make a change so
this season I feel like it really some
of our best work and we always say it
but it does just as our song says we
just keep getting better and that's not
our fault
we don't blame you for that very quickly
listen that brat house the turnaround on
that Bobby was incredible I was like
holy and yes I could smell the litter
box through the screen I heard that you
all share a trailer on set which is
insane to me because we know that isn't
what is done in Hollywood situations uh
Bobby who is the messiest Queen on that
trailer why did you you watch your mouth
why did you flance Johnny
I have the most stuff and it takes a lot
to look this good you know these other
boys
they don't know about like this hair and
these we do because we see it every day
in the trailer that we share actually
you know about it because they see it a
lot um but it does take a lot to look
you know and then the reason why we're
all in the same trailer is a we love
each other and even when there's extra
ones we all end up in the summer but
also we're in these like small
neighborhoods there's not room for five
years
Jonathan's not messy you actually come
in with your assistance you take your
stuff out you're actually really great
thank you yeah no that's that's wrong no
I think the people of Canada before we
leave want to know like what is going on
in answers what's going on next for you
you're not messy but I'm still in the
messy part it's just there's sometimes
like you have a lot of like a lot of
stuff going on yeah and there's a bit of
coffee spillage on the logo
yeah it's because you're usually doing a
performance whilst you're thinking yeah
her favorite her favorite thing is to
put her coffee in the door coffee holder
forget about it get out slam the door
and the coffee flies all over the
restaurant I do do that
you don't get your signature
I feel like you haven't done that
you just break us up no we're having fun
[Laughter]
great outfit